uh and i'm joined by the shadow
environment secretary jim mcmahon good
morning mr mcmahon
[Music]
um is labour going to support the
government's uh plans on
the how to deal with this latest wave of
omicron including uh the pre-travel
tests and so forth
well of course it was the labour party
who were calling for uh pre-testing to
take place because we're very concerned
that the government consistently threw
out the pandemic have been very late in
making the calls that are required to
keep our borders safe very late in terms
of trying to spread the control uh the
control the spread of that virus and
what we want to do is to make sure that
we don't jeopardize
out the worst thing in the world after
all the sacrifices that we've made is
that a new variant comes in and
completely takes the rug from under that
program and so it's very important the
government get a grip it's very
important that we take swift action and
frankly it shouldn't be for the
opposition to be continually one step
ahead of the government the government
needs to take control themselves
yeah but um getting a grip
would that involve or should that have
involved uh
bringing in plans to work from home or
social distancing
or indeed a ban on christmas parties um
whether or not you're ahead of the
government is that what you wanted
we've been very clear that common sense
measures that taken together keep us
safer is the way to to go and so of
course if a workplace is unsafe then
action will need to be taken but many
workplaces can be safe providing that
appropriate action is taken to maintain
social distancing to make sure that
people are supported to self-isolate and
to take sick leave if they need to and
that includes decent pay to allow people
to do that we've been very clear that
common sense interventions are far
better than a blunt instrument
in this and we want to make sure that
after the sacrifice that we've made and
listen most of us uh last year at
christmas were adhering to the rules and
we made sacrifices we didn't see our
loved ones we didn't mix we didn't have
parties in the office we adhered to the
rules after all that sacrifice that
we've made we want to look forward to
this christmas and the only way to do
that is they're going to have a very
clear plan for them to kind of get on
with the booster vaccination
roll out and to make sure that
throughout the course of that that the
messaging is really clear because the
worst thing in the world is that the
government say one thing but then do
another and people look at the actions
of the government and they get a
confused message
i'm not entirely clear about your your
own message here
would a clear plan
involve saying to people you should not
have christmas parties for example
well we've been very clear to the
government to bring forward the plan
based on the scientific evidence and
advice and it's got to be a coherent
plan we've been very clear that we do
not believe that christmas passes should
be cancelled we believe that hospitality
has been for a very difficult period and
it's very important for hospitality that
we continue uh in the way that we want
to but that can only happen if we're not
undermined by new strain variants go
into the country that completely take
apart the vaccination rollout
so what about vaccine passport for big
events would you
would you have insisted on that
we've always wanted to take a common
sense and evidence-based approach and of
course it wasn't that long ago that we
were saying very clearly that for large
gatherings uh that testing should be
taking place to make sure that if people
were carrying covered they weren't able
to spread it across a large group of
people but we've also been very clear
that it's got to be a balanced approach
and so you know you wouldn't necessarily
need it for the football for the
restaurants uh we don't want to have
unnecessary rules in place that really
undermine uh confidence in hospitality
confidence in going out over christmas
but equally we do want people to be
cautious you know we are not on the
other side of this uh yet there's still
many cases that are being identified
there's still many people who are in
hospital uh through covert and we don't
know yet the extent of the new variant
so your cautious common sense approach
is what's needed
well i don't spend too much time on this
but what you've told me is you will back
the steps of the government's taken you
would not do more than they uh have said
that they want to do on christmas
parties you would not introduce vaccine
passport you're basically telling me
exactly the same as a government
minister would tell me which is to say
let's be cautious let's be common
central and so on what's your problem
with what the government's done then
well first of all it was labor that
called for the pre-departure testing to
take place and the government will later
come in to that conclusion uh themselves
it's the labour party who's calling for
five hundred thousand test
booster vaccinations to be administered
every day and at the moment the
government's only reaching 370 000 and
so we are very clear about what's needed
we need to make sure that people are
resilient and have the booster
vaccination but the government needs to
do far more to make it accessible they
need to be invested in pop-up facilities
whether that's in
campuses on the high street in
workplaces to make sure that it is
accessible and people take that boost of
vaccination by doing that of course
they're more resilient to the virus but
equally you know the vaccination program
as it stands could easily be undermined
by a new variant that completely
undermines it and so that's why it's
really important that we have strong
borders but in doing so make sure that
we understand the implications of that
for aviation for tourism
of course we will begin to see
consumer confidence diminish it's very
important the government have a single
plan to make sure the common sense
interventions on one hand fully see
through the implications of that to make
sure that our economy and our societies
are supported
um
we've been in the north this this week
uh mr mcmahon and um
you of course you're an oldham mp you
you'll have seen the
impact of storm arwen um
do you think that what's been done is
adequate and
frankly do you think as
some people said to me uh in the
northeast if that that a
storm had hit the southeast uh do you
think that the response would have been
the same as it has been
well i'm in alden today but i was
further off uh earlier in the week when
i went to county durham to meet
residents who are directly affected by
the power outage you know and that was
now six days into the storm when i uh
visited uh one of the first things i did
in my new role in the shadow cabinet
and when you hear the real lived
experience of people you know i beggar's
belief
that in a national emergency it wasn't
uh considered a national priority you
know where was boris johnson why wasn't
cobra called to deal with this why is it
taking a week for the army to be called
in you know and i firmly believe had
this have been the case where 20 000
properties were without power in surrey
or in london the government would
absolutely have treated it with more
seriousness and i think for people
encountered who i spoke to they felt
isolated they felt angry and they felt
forgotten
michael gove who is the leveling up
secretary has been talking this week we
understand about introducing
greater devolution to different parts of
england including for example the idea
of
what i think he calls governors which
are sort of like state governors in the
united
states you were a local authority leader
would you um favor that sort of
devolution
i do think we have a very fragmented
system of devolution in england uh in a
way that is confused it's not as clear
as scotland uh wales and northern
ireland and the truth is the creation of
the metro mass has given sub-regions a
voice but the counties are voiceless
and actually if you look at the way the
government are directing money aside
from the red wall seats that they want
to support quite a lot of that is being
sent through uh mayoral combined
authorities at the disadvantage of many
of our counties and so the government do
need a single plan to make sure that
governance accountability and investment
in england is where it needs to be
whether governors are the right approach
i'm not sure i think you know kirsten
has been really clear that when we talk
about the power imbalance in this
country is because people in the
communities where they live don't
believe they've got power over the
direction of the places where they live
and so before we start talking about new
politicians being created we ought to
talk about whether people feel able to
drive the direction of the places where
they live in the communities where they
live and i think for many people they
don't feel that way particularly by the
way because the government continually
take power away from local people i mean
just look at one of the biggest things
that actually affects your area is
physical development building work
construction well actually the
government have taken that power away
from many communities in favor of
developers who quite often are not
working in the interests of the local
community and so if we're talking about
where power says it should be absolutely
rooted in the communities where people
live
okay well let's talk about power let's
talk about how you get your hands on on
some um you came second on in a
by-election in bexley this week which is
encouraging you had a 10 swing from the
conservatives which is pretty good um
but according to john curtis who is the
great authority on these things even a
10 swing repeated all over the country
still wouldn't give you a majority there
is a massive mountain to climb for labor
isn't there so we understand fully the
challenge uh ahead of us uh but also we
reflect on the progress that we have
made you know in 2019 the election was a
disaster you know people weren't willing
to even consider labour being in
government but now case dahmer is our
leader as a right to be heard but now
what we need to do is to convince people
that we've got a plan an alternative
plan for this country and that's very
much the kind of framing of the new
shadow cabinet that's very much the
framing that kirst dharma is keen to get
out there and i think actually now the
restrictions have eased and we're able
to get around the country more we are
able to speak to people in the places
where they live in a direct way that i
do believe is cutting through
and actually you know the bexar
by-election for the tourists was a
disaster uh not least of all it would
have put you know if that was uh seen
through in a general election it would
have put labour very close to majority
government but the truth is that every
day that passes the conservatives are
getting worse they are being found out
people see them for what they are which
is it's one rule for them and it's
another for everybody else and people
are fed up
with having that limiter
at your first shadow cabinet meeting did
you actually talk about the issue of
your pathway back to power which
for most observers only lies through two
pathways
one
that nigel farage takes enough votes off
the tories
to lose them many of the constituencies
that they now hold
or
that you do a deal with nicola sturgeon
did you discuss at the style cabinet how
it feels to be beholden either to nigel
farage or nicolas sturgeon or both to
get into number ten
well not really because the
conversations that we have at shadow
cabin are not defeatist conversation
they are positive con conversations
they're ambitious uh conversations and
we are ambitious not for ourselves
people who live here and so we're
absolutely clear that with our path to
government with a plan that's been set
out that by the time we get to the
general election
that we will be in a position to form a
majority government that's a project
that's exactly what we're in politics to
do
jim mcmahon thank you very much for your
time this morning